perfect song for this girl jewelry
designer Kendra Scott believe she is
living the American dream
listen that she's a college dropout
who's became an entrepreneur when she
started a business in her home Scott
just hoped to break even
16 years later that business is worth a
billion dollars Wow her stores offer a
unique experience to customers she
encourages them to interact with the
jewelry by that we mean pick it up try
it on and then customize your own piece
we spoke with the 44 year old mom of
three at her headquarters in Austin
about how she became one of the savviest
and wealthiest business women in the
United States so first put out a list
last year of America's richest self-made
women on that list Donna Karen DVF
Taylor Swift Beyonce Kendra Scott and
you rank higher than all of those women
are you sure that couldn't be an error
this is my sanctuary there's no
mistaking Kendra Scott's tremendous
success this is where we actually design
all of the product her billion dollar
company started 16 years ago with only
$500 that she used to make jewelry out
of a spare bedroom in her home did you
have any training in jewelry making so
no there were some bead shops local bead
shops if you can believe it and I would
go and take a few little beading classes
there was a little Community College I
took a class in and I really wanted to
learn what you learned in the classes
you start doing it yes so when I was
pregnant with my first son I made a
little collection and I was like you
know this is not half bad I think people
would like this so when he was three
months old I put him in a little baby
carrier and I took my collection in a
tea box and I actually have that wooden
t-box still all the little boxes and I
went store to store in Austin what's
your pitch so you know I remember before
the first store I actually was in the
car and I'll never forget that moment
because I was scared to go in I was
afraid to get turned away I was afraid
to get told no and actually the first
store I went into I did get told no and
I had to get back in the car and drive
to another store and get my courage to
go back in and try again
do you believe every new
can be turned into a yes well if you
look at the word no in a mirror it's on
so I think it's game on
it was persistence that would turn her
business idea into a company Kendra
assembled a small team of women
including her mother that she calls the
super 7 and began selling her jewelry
wholesale she caught the attention of
retail giant Nordstrom all while still
working out of that bedroom they called
and they you know after they received
order and they had an issue and they're
like we need to speak with your shipping
and receiving department I'm like so I'm
like sure of course hold one moment
please
ah Nordstrom shipping and receiving she
like gets up like she's been doing her
whole life this is Janet shipping and
receiving for Kendra Scott I think it is
amazing as her business grew so did her
family but shortly after having her
second son Kendra became a single mom it
was a challenge she met with motivation
so how old were your son's then when you
got divorced
one in three one in three so they're
babies so then are you really feeling I
have to make this a success pressure
about that of course I did what's your
decision at that time well you know it
was really hard because people would say
well you just need to go get an angel
investor and I'm like where do these
angels hang out you know like how do you
find one of these magical angels that
you're talking about I mean people made
it sound like well you just got to go
find it and I think for us a pivotal
moment was after the recession hit
because I was running our business just
doing hoe sale I wasn't selling our own
retail direct to customer and when the
recession hit so many businesses had
trouble and I knew that if I didn't
change my business model we would lose
our business so it's you and your core
girl yes and you say what retail stores
are closing everywhere and I'm saying I
want to open our own retail store I want
our own New York showroom it really was
a go big go big or go home
and it was that we it may not work and
we may not have jobs when this is over
but if you're willing to try to do
something radical with me it could work
it worked all right
today Kendra Scott has
before retail stores all around the
country and one in London the super 7
yep they're still here it's a work
environment kendra has strive to make
unique we give this to our to our
amazing Hendrix cot family members there
are lots of perks for the company's
2,000 employees 98% of which are women
working on everything from product
design to sales can I see the green
people like how can it be that much
women and is it you know how is the work
environment is it caddy is it it's the
opposite we're rooting for each other
we're cheer are each other's
cheerleaders and that's the environment
that we instill here we hire nice people
we hire kind people and when you do that
it's amazing what can happen
kids can't get out of the hospital right
now so we bring colorbar to them giving
back is part of her business model
Kendra Karras is a program working with
hospitals nationwide including Dell
Children's here in Austin it's part of
our culture of our company you know
everyone is so proud that they're making
a difference and they're so thrilled and
excited to be part of something that
they're also getting to leave their mark
on it is what I am most proud of and the
bigger that we've gotten the more we can
do what is it that you want people to
take away from your story a lot of times
in our lives there are things that
happen to us that are good and sometimes
things happen to us that are that are
bad you know we lose sometimes people we
love or we go through a divorce or we
have these struggles in our life and I
think the lesson that I've learned over
this last 16 years as those can be gifts
so I would just say in those moments
take a breath and go it's not over this
could be just the beginning and that is
how she looks at stuff Norah you asked
the question I was going to tag with cuz
Norah just said did she remarry yes she
remarried she's very happy they haven't
so now she has three sons it was one of
those love stories where she and her
husband locked eyes across the room and
fell in love yesterday was her birthday
and the thing that's so great about her
joy which I'm wearing now she says three
generations teenagers moms and
grandmothers all
where it because we all like it and
she's right it's beautiful she's right
and she is quite a businesswoman really
it's a great example